good day and welcome i'm jack van horn from the
university of virginia please allow me to welcome
you to this edition of our 2020 2021 foundations
of biomedical data science seminar series
this lecture is supported by the uva's integrated
translational health institute of virginia the uva
brain institute the college of arts and sciences
the school of data science and by a grant from the
national institutes of general medical sciences
it's my honor and privilege to welcome our speaker
today dr jessica turner associate professor
of psychology from georgia state university
she completed her bachelor of arts degree um in
psychology and mathematics from swarthmore college
a masters of arts in social sciences from the
university of california irvine in 1992 and
in 1997 completed her phd in psychology
from the university of california irvine
she has been an assistant professor in residence
at the cal irvine and from 2010 to 2013
an assistant professor at the university of new
mexico where she was part of the translational
neuroscience mind research network in
albuquerque new mexico since presently
she has been an associate professor in the
department of psychology at georgia state
university in atlanta and under the direction of
professor turner her lab investigates the genetics
underlying brain structural changes in chronic
schizophrenia as well as the genetic influences
on functional and structural neural imaging
measurements in many other neuropsychological
disorders and diseases she has a particular
focus on the development of formal computable
representations of neuroimaging experiments
the experimental variables involved in the
results of data from automated data sharing and
meta-analyses within neurobiology all of her
work is conducted in close collaboration
with psychiatrists computer scientists
geneticists and neuroscientists in research on
the genetics of brain function and dysfunction
she has been a key participant and contributor
to several large-scale nih-funded programs in
brain research notably the biomedical informatics
research network coordinating center the skids
connect project as well as many others and her
lecture today is entitled enigma and coin stack
turning small data sets into big ones as always we
are streaming this lecture live and for recording
via youtube if you are watching on youtube thank
you so much for joining us also our specially
selected uh 2020 2021 biomedical data science
innovation lab participants are encouraged to
submit any questions for dr turner via the chat
feature in their zoom sessions i will synthesize
these questions and ask them on your behalf during
about the last 10 minutes or so of dr turner's
lecture and with that welcome jess thank you so
much we are really looking forward to your lecture
thank you hopefully everybody can hear me and here
we are um move on through it thank you so much for
inviting me uh to give this presentation today i
want to talk about um really a culmination or the
current stage of a long progress of creating big
data sets from smaller ones there's been a long
history in neuroimaging of which uh dr van horn
has been was a key player in helping neuro imaging
researchers to share their data to take data sets
from individual studies um so that they could be
combined considered compared in ways that you
can't if you just look at the literature so
today i wanted to talk about two efforts that have
been ongoing in this progress over the last decade
one of which is the enigma effort and its working
groups which is a largely human dependent approach
to large-scale data sharing and analysis and one
of which is coin stack which is a more automated
approach and these two groups have actually gotten
together which is why i have an enigma coinstack
presentation to talk to you about so for those
of you who don't know enigma for those of you
who do i'm going to apologize about half the
talks about enigma and its history enigma
stands for enhancing neuroimaging genetics through
meta-analysis it was really started in 2009 it was
largely the brainchild of dr paul
thompson now at usc and at that time
um hard to believe as it was but if you
cast your mind back into the early 2000s
those of us who are trying to put together brain
measurements neuroimaging and genetics really had
a hope that if we could get to 200 500 maybe
a thousand subjects that we would be able to
identify genetic effects on brain measurements
more very robustly um and it and it was becoming
very clear that that wasn't the case that we were
going to take thousands of subjects in which is
larger than any one person can collect and paul's
real stroke of genius was to recognize that we
could actually um leave the data where it is um so
everybody had data sets of 100 people 200 people
which we thought were astoundingly large for
neuroimaging but they weren't large enough and the
idea would be could we actually just interact with
everybody who has those data who has genetic data
genome-wide scan data and brain imaging data and
have everybody do the same analysis so voluntarily
agree to do the same analysis on their own
data and then aggregate those results for
a meta-analysis and that way we don't have to
jump through all the hoops of data sharing we
don't have to jump through all the hoops of moving
the data so that you have 10 000 data sets in one
university's um resources but we just send
summary results back and forth and there's
a huge lowering of the bar when people when
you say oh i don't have to give you my data
i just have to do some analysis and we
can actually um we can actually put it
together and do a meta-analysis but it's
not the same as a literature meta-analysis
because it is a prospective what we call
perspective meta-analysis because everybody
does the same analysis as opposed to reading the
literature and doing everybody you know perhaps
have done having done their own idiosyncratic
analysis and and published it so it avoids the
heterogeneity of an analysis heterogeneity of
analysis that you get from a sort of standard
literature driven meta-analysis and it also avoids
to some extent the um the file drawer problem
where data that's too small that doesn't find a
significant result doesn't get published and you
never know about it so in this case we're really
asking people to reach into their file drawer
and reuse their own data and it turned out
that he got a huge response he literally
just emailed you know friends and friends and
family and uh shipped around his his imaging
networks and imaging genetics networks and had
a positive response from quite a few uh people
so in 2012 these were the the groups from around
the country who were participating in the first
analyses by 2014 it had grown tremendously
and more recently it's now at 43 countries
researchers across 43 countries it's organically
organized into 51 working groups and 31
or around 31 different disorders and it's
just really taken off so from its original
analyses which were literally genomic association
studies of subcortical methods so they had a group
working on how do we actually standardize the
subcortical protocol so that everybody can do it
how do we do the genetics in such a way that we
can do the meta-analysis appropriately afterwards
that was sort of the first the first start since
then there have been many many groups working
on different interactions of genetics
and imaging different aspects of genetics
epigenetics etc how do we actually deal with that
how do we collaborate with other imaging genetics
groups that maybe are not part of enigma but are
doing their own thing within the imaging there
have been a huge number of imaging protocols
suitable for multi-site meta-analysis and mega
analysis that have been developed the initial
analyses sort of ignored disorder even though
many of the studies which were participating in
the meta-analysis had collected their data because
they were interested in schizophrenia
or bipolar disorder attention deficit
once the first papers came out the again a sort of
self-organization occurred whereby working groups
who were part of the original analysis
but now wanted to focus on schizophrenia
bipolar disorder etc grew up and then
those have expanded now into again over
over 30 different disorders that are using
these same sorts of models uh to exam examine
neuroimaging in their disorder as well as other
questions that are perhaps not disease related
um maturation over the lifespan changes over
a shorter period of time lateralization etc
um now the reason enigma can be so successful
is it was in many cases really dependent
on previously existing informatics or easy
informatics to to implement for those of you who
may not be familiar with neuroimaging free surfer
is a piece of software that's been around for
probably 30 years that has been used to analyze
structural images to look at gray and white matter
volumes and shape and other kinds of measures and
they have used the same directory structure since
the early 90s to store the inputs and outputs
of their data so that was highly standardized
not optimized but highly standardized and
everybody knew how to work with them so we could
easily write scripts that would work with these
directory trees pull out the measurements that we
really want which could then be automated using in
our the original cases it was all our scripts that
could run on anybody's system to do the regression
zip it all up and ship it back to the central site
for a meta-analysis so completely dependent on
people making sure that they could run free surfer
run the scripts run the r scripts but these r
scripts could be standardized across everybody's
sites for a standard analysis we all would agree
on exactly what regressions we want to do etc so
in the first paper from 2012 they ended up looking
at data from 13 000 subjects this was really the
first success of enigma in many ways looking at
human hippocampal and intracranial volumes and the
entire genome or genome-wide association study and
identifying regions in the hippocampus that didn't
quite hit um even with 13 000 data points didn't
quite hit significance um but uh it did seem to be
identifying areas that were related to genes
which were important in brain development
very nice kind of results and the important thing
for me the the reason that i'm such a fan of
the enigma approach is really shown here in this
forest plot where what you're seeing is every site
that contributed data to the to the first meta
analysis and the effect uh the effect size and
a confidence interval for that data set for that
locus and and hippocampal volume and you can see
that individually no site reaches significance
none of these results would ever have been
published in the literature as being genome-wide
association significant in any way but the trend
is very consi surprisingly consistent across all
of the data sets so that when you look at the
consensus results in a meta-analysis you really
see that there there seems to be an effect there
and the lovely thing about it was not only do
they do one in meta-analysis but they did two
um using a similar number of subjects and the the
meta the replication showed exactly the same sort
of result leading to a very exciting uh finding
and then of course they could uh replicate that
and extend it the next paper in 2015 that looked
at all of the subcortical brain structures
included data from 30 30 000 participants around
the world and uh excitedly it sort of turned out
that the the hippocampus is not where we should
have been looking the putamen is really where
the strong genetic effects just outstandingly
strong genetic effects were found when you had
the power to really aggregate this data and these
results and look at it across 30 000 subjects and
of course more recently now up to 50 000 subjects
and they're able to do the same analysis across
the entire uh cerebral cortex looking at all of
the uh brain regions there and identifying um
a genome-wide significant effects on on cortical
gray matter thickness and other measurements
so of course these this approach is
imminently scalable you've i've already shown
that um we've been broken up into working groups
well shall we say loosely organized into working
groups because many people of course have multiple
um trans diagnostic interests and participate in
multiple of these research groups but each one of
the groups has looked at case control differences
using these approaches aggregating results
from around the world to identify where do
we see case control effects across the cortex
and the subcortex um and how and now we can
say how does that actually relate um across
the different disorders um so that we have
major depression bipolar disorder uh theo van
erp and i run the schizophrenia working group
and you can see of course that you can compare
very nicely the cortical pattern of results across
these different disorders and each of these papers
and analyses really pulls from thousands of cases
and controls around the world really helping to
nail down these effects and effect sizes in these
in these disorders of course not everything
is gray matter our first analyses really
dependent on on free surfer and fsl for for
their analysis but of course there's also
diffusion tensor imaging data resting state
functional uh imaging data and uh the latest
uh development effort is in a pipeline for
analyzing magnetic resonance spectroscopy
results across multiple sites and studies and
again remember all of this data is collected
um long before it's analyzed for an enigma
approach these are all data sets in all of these
studies that are previously collected so they
were collected as best fit the needs of the people
running those studies at the time as best fit the
abilities of whatever scanning centers they were
using at the time so they are highly heterogeneous
data collection methods neural imaging parameters
etc and so half the challenge in developing an
enigma pipeline is really identifying what is
it that we can do to address the heterogeneity
across these techniques the same the different
techniques using these samples that somehow
maintains the effect sizes and the sensitivity
across the samples we don't want to just wipe
out any effects that we might be finding but
at the same time we don't want to introduce
artifact so briefly this is an example from 2013
introducing the enigma dti pipeline where they
had access to multiple family studies and they
could identify that the header the heritability
of white matter was the same when it was run
through the enigma dti pipeline whether they did
a meta-analysis or a mega analysis they didn't
introduce any artifacts and the overall pattern
results was very similar across the different
white matter tracks which gave us some confidence
that this dti pipeline was what we wanted and then
the schizophrenia groups the bipolar groups and
the major depression groups have all published
the white matter case control effects using this
pipeline and in a recent paper that just came out
maybe i think this past month the working with a
japanese consortium so the kokoro consortium is an
uh a japanese version of enigma where they have
their own multi-site um data set aggregation
and analysis approach for meta-analysis and they
basically used the enigma pipeline and looked at
their schizophrenia samples and looked at the um
the what the effect sizes that they were finding
and how that correlated with the effect size
that the enigma schizophrenia group had already
published and as you can see there's a whoppingly
high correlation so it's highly reproducible in
these case control effects across different parts
of the white matter in international samples
bipolar disorder also very high correlation not as
tight as in schizophrenia and in major depression
still a good correlation but um weaker probably
due to the the heterogeneity of depression
i always thought schizophrenia was a highly
heterogeneous disorder but it's got nothing on
on major depression which is just incredibly
um uh different in its different different
presentations so given that enigma is hit 10 years
there's actually a special issue all about enigma
looking at sort of a ten-year retrospective that
just came out in human brain mapping uh quite uh
recently i think almost now that maybe out into
two different um issues and it's covering um over
30 papers there's really quite a lot there you can
spend the whole year just reading your way through
this this issue and in many cases it really
falls under three themes one is looking at
working groups and what they have done either some
of the newer working groups such as epilepsy or
um or stroke recovery which is some of the
newer working groups or comparisons across
the different working groups so the adhd and
the autism groups have been working together
more recently and it's a review of
what what they've been doing and what
they've been finding etc there are a number of
methods paper so what do we know about the dti
pipeline what have we been able to use it to find
out comparing meta versus mega analysis so what do
we see when we do a meta-analysis versus actually
pull all the data together into one location
reproducibility questions and then empirical
findings either from using the enigma approach
such as looking at subcortical shape shape
alterations or trying to apply enigma findings
in the smaller clinical non-enigma data sets
some of the newer disease groups have really
tackled the heterogeneity of their diseases
and these more recent papers are showing that
so for example with schizophrenia we know that
schizophrenia is a highly heterogeneous disorder
but in our analyses we could basically say look
everybody's either schizophrenic or they're not
they've got this diagnosis or they don't and we're
just going to roll with that and look at what we
can find just to get the get the ball rolling
we've looked at some symptoms severity profiles
etc but in epilepsy and stroke and epilepsy
of course the locus of where the epileptic
or the foci of the epileptic seizures could
be in very different places around the brain
in different data sets stroke studies of course
stroke can be in very different parts of the brain
and they really had to tackle the heterogeneity
of their data and how are they going to put that
together in these large-scale meta-analyses
the anxiety working group had to deal with the
organization of anxiety disorders they didn't
just focus on a particular anxiety disorder
so they really took to heart that within anxiety
you have general anxiety and then you've got the
social anxiety and phobic anxieties and other
anxieties and they wanted to break to say
try to tease apart what is specific to anxiety
and what is specific to the different disorders
or what is general to anxiety and what is specific
to the different anxiety subdivisions if you will
very interesting reading and approaches there one
of the translations of the enigma findings to the
clinic is the regional vulnerability index that
peter kochenov and his team uh have identified
and it really takes advantage of the fact that
all the enigma findings are downloadable um so
across for example the schizophrenia findings we
have for every brain region from the free surface
free surfer cortical output we know what the case
control effect size is and what its confidence
uh range is so we have a profile if
you will of what the schizophrenic
effects are across the brain and we can apply this
to any data set any neuroimaging data set that you
might have where if you start with your controls
you can get sort of the mean for your sample
what is the mean thickness or measurement for
example of every brain region in this parcellation
you can then for each subject look at how
they deviate from your controls so for your
your controls are going to obviously have some
variability around the mean and your patients if
you have individuals with schizophrenia will also
deviate from the mean of the healthy controls and
so every subject now has a sort of vector
of z-scores showing whether where they are
uh deviating from the mean and by how much and
of course you can then correlate that with um the
enigma schizophrenia findings across these same
regions so that the regional vulnerability index
is the correlation of between their
regional z-scores and the cohen's d scores
across the region so a higher correlation means
that their pattern of thickness deviations from
the norm is more similar to what we've seen in
case control differences in the worldwide sample
which is a lovely idea and what can you do with
it and what um peter's team did was say well we
have you know 120 or 200 patients and a bunch of
controls and we can look within the patients at
those who are earlier in their disorder or
intermediate their disorder or those who've
had the disorder for for many decades and look
at their subcortical measures their cortical
measures their white matter and they actually came
up with a way to do a regional vulnerability index
um that combined all of these measures and they
could show that they're basically their controls
um have no regional regional vulnerability
patients do have a regional vulnerability
across all modalities so they correlate with
what's been seen in these worldwide samples
and in subcortically and in white matter
you can actually see effects across the
duration of illness so that patients who
are sort of early in their diagnostic stage
look you know a little bit more like healthy
controls than that do the folks who are more
chronic in all cases and the substance abuse
disorders working group also looked at a very
similar kind of approach saying we have our own
patterns of findings in substance use how does
that compare to the psychiatric disorders where
do we see a similar pattern where do we not
um so enigma of course people always ask
how do i join up how do i get involved
if you have imaging data that is relevant to any
of the questions that any of the working groups
are are looking at whether it's disorder related
or methodology related etc um just you can you can
talk to the chair of the of the working group and
and get involved usually people are affiliated
with some data set either directly or indirectly
if you have a method that you're interested in
trying out generally speaking many of the working
groups are very open to that we've certainly seen
folks from you know bipolar or ptsd working groups
come over to schizophrenia and say hey we're
finding this really interesting thing in these
other groups can we try it in schizophrenia even
though they themselves don't have schizophrenia
data and sometimes if you have an interesting
question you can certainly make a connection
within the relevant enigma working group
i have had people come to me and say oh i can
i get access to the enigma data because i want
to do this the other thing i have a new
approach and usually the response is look
make a connection with someone who has the
relevant data show us how it's being done on that
particular data set and then you'll you'll get um
the working group leaders and the data set liaison
sort of going sure i'm happy to give it a shot on
on my data but you want to sort of you don't want
to just walk up and say i can't hand you the data
for enigma because everybody controls their own
within the large-scale enigma analysis of course
we've identified privacy issues one of the reasons
why enigma exists is so we don't have to actually
give away our data and within that special issue
vince calhoun has written a paper about the
software he's been developing specifically
to address the issues of privacy within the
data sharing drive within the neuro imaging
community so vince calhoun who's now at
georgia state has been developing the
collaborative informatics and neuroimaging suite
toolkit for anonymous computation or coin stack
and it is exactly what it sounds like it is a
collaborative informatics and no imaging suite
so it's a data management data um processing uh
suite of tools that is now available for anonymous
collaborative computation so the idea
is very much like the enigma model
someone can install the coinstack software
link it up to the data that they have available
and collaborate with other people around the world
who want to do these same kinds of analyses on
similar kind of data without having to actually
upload your data or send it to everybody you
want to collaborate with etc it allows obviously
researchers from around the world to collaborate
with the automated approach it can now include
decentralized learning algorithms advanced
statistical and machine learning analyses so
that you don't you can do iterative algorithms
iterative computations which previously had
required that all the data be in one place that
you can iterate over it uh because certainly
the human driven approach that we've used in
enigma largely is not conducive to to shipping
information back and optimizing parameters etc etc
you can you only get one shot um but with these
automated approaches you can have the you can now
decentralize your iterative algorithms and and
apply them without transmitting individual level
data and you can incorporate differentially
private computations in the software level so
that you can protect against malicious attacks
that might be trying to reconstruct your data
and get at the privacy information that you're
trying to hide so we have we can actually work
in privacy protection at that level and currently
it is of course open source free software um
easily extensible it's based in docker it'll run
computations in r python matlab etc and it runs
on windows mac and linux obviously there's still
a lot to do with it um but basically the lead site
defines the local analysis that will be run
locally and the global analysis that would be run
at the lead site when it gets all the results back
in the kind of automation of the enigma approach
the participating sites basically can see exactly
how their data is being used they're not giving up
control of their data in any way they agree to
allow their data to be used they then join the
consortium get the analyses that are supposed to
be done and when everything's ready the lead site
actually fires off the analysis which is then run
automatically at every site no post docs required
and um and returns the intermediate data to
the lead site we have implemented of course
regression as well as these d centralized more
interesting kinds of algorithms perhaps including
deep learning and independent components analysis
and support vector machines etc and of course
we've bundled up the r scripts to try to
do uh replications of the enigma analyses
and so uh vince and theo van erp and i have
sort of put together the enigma schizophrenia
and coin stack efforts and were recently funded
or actually refunded last year to ask questions
about enigma schizophrenia or really
about schizophrenic brain measures
and negative symptoms so within schizophrenia
we were very interested in negative symptoms
we already had papers out looking at across the
enigma schizophrenia working group looking at
negative symptoms and cortical thickness and
had total negative symptoms severities related
to various areas in the inferior frontal cortex
but that's really not the final word we know that
structure and white matter and function
probably all play a role in identifying
what's going on with negative symptoms and with
the coin stack interactions and the coin stack
infrastructure we could look at each one of
these individually against the negative symptom
measures we could look at multivariate
combinations of these different measures
and we can of course lead to um machine
learning approaches to try to predict
from combinations of these features what the
negative symptoms are that any given patient is
suffering from and then we could try to generalize
that by interacting with the enigma bipolar
disorder group getting them to do the same sorts
of analyses and then generalize that to major
depression to see whether the negative symptoms
the anhedonia apathy etc play a role in what we
see in major depression or really or whether
um the psychosis disorders are very different
so within schizophrenia there are actually
um very different negative symptom profiles
across men and women um generally speaking women
seem to be more affected women with schizophrenia
can be more affected by mood and and depressive
symptoms and the affect the affective symptoms
whereas men generally tend to have more severe
negative symptoms apathy and hedonia withdrawal of
all sorts but it's not specific to mood disorders
and so we use this as an initial examination
within the coinstack framework to say can we just
look at sex differences in our negative symptoms
measurements across a number of different sites
so we had as a first test we had seven different
sites that had collected as you can see very
small samples 30 28 30 subjects each with
a breakdown of men and women participants same
general age duration of illness varying from
very early on in their duration of a very short
duration of illness very long duration of illness
at every site um the sands is the scales for
the assessment of negative symptoms and again
within each site there's really quite a range from
individuals with really no negative symptoms where
most of their symptoms might have been more of
the positive symptoms like hallucinations but
they didn't have a lot of the negative symptoms
of withdrawal and apathy and blunted affect etc
and then there are other people within each
site that had quite severe negative symptoms
and so we could actually run across we could use
the coinstack in coinstack infrastructure to run a
factor analysis on the different negative
symptoms and look at the sex differences
across the negative symptom factors and then we
could look at the meta-analysis and we said we
basically what would have taken um a few months of
rolling things out to individual sites we could do
over the course of an hour by just setting
it up and and letting it run automatically
we did a hierarchical factor analysis for those
who are interested in sort of the nitty-gritty
of our negative symptoms there's a two factor
solution which is a motivation and expressiveness
um and then there's a five-factor solution
that's really embedded in the two-factor solution
and what we were seeing was generally speaking
men had more severe negative symptoms relative to
women and this was really only significant in the
expressive factor and then factors four and five
which dealt with which really contributed to the
expressive factor show the same pattern so we're
this is very nice and that we're replicating
what's been seen in the literature and
particularly in large scale um analyses where
they aggregated all the data and ran it all
together we could actually um run this in an
automated system and get what we expect to see
and then we can step forward and say okay we
did that we've got our coin tax system working
let's look at brain volumes because what do we
see with our negative symptoms and and brain
measurements and again using um the coin stack
infrastructure and some of the sites couldn't
do that so they would have to run it themselves
and we'd put it all together but um using the
coin stack infrastructure we could look at um
avolition and anedonia which are two of the
negative symptoms of schizophrenia that are
considered to be related to sort of positive
valence um sort of positive emotions it's sort of
a lack of positive emotions abolition and anedonia
and then deficits in social processing
which is asociality or blunted um
withdrawal from social interactions blunted
affect and um and no no talking basically elogia
and we could again use these analyses to
do exactly the same sorts of analyses i
was actually expecting to see a lot of the
inferior frontal regions being related to
negative symptoms as we see here because
that is what we had seen in previous analyses
when we looked at just total symptom
severity as opposed to breaking it down
and seeing which negative symptoms were related
um to the brain regions because it turns out the
positive valence seems to be related to
on the areas that we were seeing before
but the social processing is a very different um
pattern and it's really fantastic to be able to
to look at this we're still wrapping this up this
is sort of initial uh primary results we have a
few more sites that are coming in for analysis and
of course our next developments are just to say
we know that structure is just the beginning of
the question we're working on the dti analysis
similarly and resting state and then put it all
together because the test will be can we actually
use these brain measures to really predict the
different negative symptom profiles that we have
across different individuals in these data sets
so in summary we've got a few minutes here so
large-scale data management and particularly
management of access to the data for data
sharing um as well as methods for large-scale data
analysis and meta-analysis are really becoming
duragur if you will in our imaging certainly
more much more common the analyses are becoming
more powerful and more nuanced over time
the heterogeneity of the disorders can
really be attacked with these kinds of large-scale
approaches combinations of meta and mega analysis
can be very uh informative again meta analysis
is where you leave the data in one place mega
analyses is usually where you have to combine
the data there are approaches for performing
what is effectively a mega analysis in a
decentralized environment so that's very promising
because it is really the best of both worlds
structural functional and dti analysis pipelines
are currently available with others coming and
novel approaches of course to these decentralized
analyses are becoming available and very
powerful for being able to really access
federated or decentralized data to be able
to get the power of these large-scale data
sets without pulling it all together and
having to invest in massive data repositories
the initial results from enigma all of their
working groups are are public and can be reused
the initial code from coinstack is available on
our github site and it's in these slides as well
this allows for comparisons across disorders
and diagnostic boundaries and it allows for
prediction and classic classification techniques
without data sharing when you put enigma
data access and and coin stack techniques
together um so that's hopefully uh the
beginnings of the future for these kinds of
analyses so in conclusion i do want to again
address and remind everybody the key issues
of the power that comes from these kinds
of questions the computational efficiency that
comes from these kinds of approaches and shared
data access shared data considerations it
really pushes open science and reproducibility
forward because these meta-analyses in particular
with the forest plots really highlight the
variability across different data sets and what
you might expect to see if you run it yourself
on your own data set but of course is pushing team
science forward and of course advancing science
by interacting together to try to answer
the same question once and for all as
opposed to having to do it multiple times
and argue about it in the literature per se
so we can of course download github so i wanted to
make sure everybody has access to that information
we're very happy to hear from you if you download
it and try to run it or want to get involved
and i did want to acknowledge both the
nsf and the nih support that has gone
into all of these efforts i didn't encore include
all of the enigma enigma grants but certainly the
ones that have been interacted with uh coinstack
this is uh vince's teams many of whom are working
on developing these algorithms and and software
as well as other questions this is my lab um
at georgia state many of whom are interacting with
uh the enigma approaches and this is um a group of
the enigma a subset if you will of the enigma
working group uh leaders getting together for
their annual meeting um before the organization
for human brain mapping uh meeting in 2019
back when we could actually all
get together and stand together
and hopefully we'll be able to do that
again in the future so thank you very much
dr turner thank you so much for that great
overview of enigma and coin stack and it's
uh several examples of their application um that
have led to some pretty prominent peer-reviewed
literature that's fantastic and thank you so
much for sharing that i want to invite our
biomedical data science innovation lab attendees
to submit questions via their chat feature in zoom
and while those are accumulating jess
i'd like to ask you a couple of things
while we wait um so it looks like enigma has
solved many of the sociological issues that
are involved in data sharing and certainly
promotes uh open science and collaboration
i'm curious if you've also solved the cat hurting
problem of getting all those people to do things
in a timely fashion and answer emails and uh
what's some of the what's some of the the the
coordination that has to go into having um some of
these uh multi-site multi-country multi-time zone
collaborations well you know there's there's
an entire book that could probably be written
about lessons learned from trying to run these
large-scale techniques uh and i'm sure anybody
who's done it whether it's in neuroimaging or
geoscience or whatever would have would have
similar approaches um but no we have not solved
the cat hurting problem and in many cases and i
i can speak as somebody who's been um running
the working group for probably longer than i
should uh in many cases uh the the energy of
the of the people who have joined more recently
is embarrassing to those of us who've been
around for a while and are starting to slow down
and not be able to focus on these these analyses
quite as much as we should like to um so no i
think a lot of it has to do with having um well
there's a number of things one is we we found that
co-chairing working groups is really important
no one person can do it by themselves and having
two people sort of you know keeps it it's it
is a bit of cat hurting but at the same time
it's a bit like having cats that play together you
know they're much more likely to to stay healthy
if they're not doing it on their own and feeling
like it's all on their own so i strongly recommend
anybody who's starting up a group like this to
have a team going into it as as leaders and then
there have been a number of graduate
students and postdocs who have made
enigma projects their their dissertation and i
think to a person they have all said that was
probably slowing things down tremendously not from
the point of view of enigma enigma was quite happy
to see you know the larger groups were very happy
to see um somebody dedicated to these projects and
actually getting papers out in the papers have
been very successful but each individual sort
of said i probably ended up taking a year or two
longer with my dissertation than i would have if i
had focused on something a little bit smaller and
they basically recommend that you you do this as a
post-doc but not necessarily as a graduate student
yeah i was going to ask about the use of enigma
as a device for undergraduate graduate or you
know postdoctoral education and i was curious
uh if you know about examples of that sounds like
there's some graduate students who do this is
this something that you have guys have considered
kind of broadening to cover more of the spectrum
educational spectrum um no because it's
hard enough to keep it moving much less
turn it into anything else um but no i think it's
really a brilliant idea i certainly have brought
people in in my lab as as graduate students a
number of them are working on you know learning
r and trying to turn these analyses
into r and what does it take to actually
work with these kinds of international consortia
and i know other groups have written graduate
basically funding grants to try to fund graduate
students to work on it we don't have a coordinated
r25 for example like you have or anything like
that but i think that's probably something we
should we should consider oh fantastic um one of
the questions that is coming in is uh about the
um kind of geographic diversity and ethnic
diversity that you have in enigma um and that
seems it's a lot of the data are coming from uh
european yes and people of european ancestry and
whether or not there's any interest in including
other populations are performing kind of trans
ethnic meta yes yes absolutely absolutely if you
look at our maps i mean every time we got you
know we got researchers on new continents or new
countries uh there was always a a celebration um
and it's been it's been very interesting trying
to work with people from around the world i think
obviously from the point of view of the genetics
um europe and the us sort of had a running start
on that um china japan and many of the asian
countries certainly have whopping um groups
doing those analyses and they are much more
open to doing meta analyses than to actually
sharing the data um and i think that has certainly
helped out a lot and they were absolutely um
included in some of the more recent ones the
first the first paper was largely caucasian
but certainly as the genetic abilities for
cross cross racial cross ethnic comparisons
have gotten better that's sort of grown up hand
in hand with worldwide enigma genetics analyses
that's nice absolutely i mean africa unfortunately
many of the countries in africa are still
not at that point um but we're looking forward
to the day when when we'll have dots all
over that part of the world as well that'd be
fantastic now you mentioned there was a lot of
the work that you described was looking at the
data from a meta-analytic point of view and i
mean that's part of the way enigma is structured
is to look for um kind of meta-analytic findings
but you also mentioned that there are some mega
analytic tools and machinery that exists and
obviously meta-analysis is going to be an analysis
of those analyses but getting all the raw data
together is kind of a different scale of analysis
and it puts more of the onus on getting all that
data into either one space or at least fewer
spaces in order to kind of do it efficiently
what are some of the things which are happening uh
that uh support mega analysis well that's a that's
a great a great question and it's it over the last
10 years there's been sort of ups and downs if
you will um because certainly as as you noted the
meta-analytic approach was really what let enigma
get rolling because people said oh oh i can i
can do this i don't have to give away my data
um and then there was a sort of pushback as
some of the first papers came out and of course
reviewers you know reviewer two always
wants another analysis um and that slows
down analysis slows down paper responses when
you have to now distribute your analyses to
you know 30 places and get the results back and
integrate it and revise the paper accordingly
and so a number of the working groups said can
we start sharing data because literally for the
purposes of writing the papers you know to say
when an analysis comes back we need to be able
to have access to the data very quickly to be
able to run these analyses and what they were
finding is that many of the groups were in the
early days so we're talking you know 2012 2013-14
many of the groups were willing to share the free
surfer output so they could share for example the
um subject level level volumes or or measurements
but not the raw images so when they when they were
doing mega analyses they could get mega analyses
at the level at that level so at the level
of the spreadsheet at the level of the um the
regional volumes or the tractography volumes etc
they could do that but they couldn't necessarily
share the the raw images with the invocation of
the gdpr that's become more difficult sure so
they were just getting that up and rolling and
becoming you know sort of the standard way
of figuring that out and then then even the
european countries said no sorry we really have
to have to you know pull back on that um so in
many cases those of us who sort of stuck with the
meta-analytic approach or focusing on coin stack
and these automated approaches um i have have uh
sort of had to step in to say you know there's
there's still things we can do the world isn't
over just because you can't share your raw data we
can put in this software layer that allows access
to the data allows access to these kinds of mega
analyses we wanted to do without having to while
protecting everybody's privacy and confidentiality
what are some of the issues with the genetics
data um i guess this is probably all singular
yeah single nucleotide polymorphism data yeah
um and you know presumably some of the data is
you know older using different chip technology
and there's some there's some heterogeneity there
and of course increasingly there's interest
in getting you know full genome sequencing
how is tell us a little bit more about that what
are some of the issues there and how do you expect
things to change as people are starting to you
know get gigabytes worth of oh yeah genome data
well let's that is um an area of active
development okay for just the reasons that
you've highlighted because we're now looking
at you know genome-wide association data was
coming out in 2005 2006 um and it's now
2020 and so as you yeah this date there
is incredibly heterogeneous um genetic data and a
great deal one of the reasons the first paper took
three years to write was to figure out how to
um deal with that and how to how to do quality
assurance on it when you you know you hand off
code and everybody goes oh yeah yeah we're using
the right build and oh yeah yeah we're doing
this and we're doing that how do you actually
make sure that they that it's been done in with
some sort of objective measurement on the data
how do you check for making sure that they don't
have relatives in their sample or if they do
you know that those have been taken into account
properly so there's a huge amount of effort
put into that and that's just as you pointed out
for the single nucleotide polymorphism data and it
just expands as you move into the newer techniques
of methylation measurements and and other kinds
of and whole genome sequencing etc so that is an
area where that's one of the reasons that genomics
working group is huge and they're collaborating
with international genetics groups as well
um to try to develop methods that are robust
to you know having an undergrad implement the
scripts on your data set um you want you know who
doesn't have a dissertation in genetics behind
them but you can still make robust techniques
that they can use and it looks like there's also
some working groups on epigenetics yeah and it
looked like there might be some gene expression
activities going on as well so it's not just
the um you know the variation in atc's and g's
but their expression and any epigenetic factors
is that right absolutely absolutely requires a
huge amount of you know conversation and trial
and error to get it right uh yeah absolutely i
mean for those of us who are just still kind of
coming to grips with you know genetics uh having
to remember our biochemistry it's just that whole
that whole side of things just keeps marching
away from me personally and i it's a continual
unbelievable i love my collaborations with the
folks who really can focus on the genetics because
they don't really care about the brain and how we
measure the brain but they can tell me everything
about the latest and greatest understanding of how
the structure of the chromosome the way it's
bent affects the the expression of the genes
so you really it's not just knowing the gene and
how it correlates you have to know where it is and
you know what else is going on absolutely
remarkable and the second i think i understand
it and try to implement anything oh no that's
that's not how we do it you haven't factored in
the you know the the the gc bias and i got to
take that into account oh okay great i didn't know
about that um uh one of our attendees is asking
um what specific areas are longitudinal studies
um which are being undertaken within enigma and
um this particular um person is particularly
interested in uh sex difference uh research
across the lifespan into things like dementia
risk is there things aren't related to this um
from a longitudinal point yes yes yes yes um
paul thompson works closely with uh nada jahanshan
also at usc and neda is running a um grant a very
small grant on enigma sex differences where what
she is doing is not actually running any analyses
but every group that does an analysis we almost
always include sex as a covariate but it's a
covariate of no interest we usually just want to
account for it but we don't really care about it
and what she's doing is saying please send me
your results anytime you include sex differences
in your model send me the results so we can
look at the effects of sex differences and
really try to put that all together in like
this massive dashboard where you can integrate
where do you see sex differences whether it's
in case control effects or in changes over time
because we do have longitudinal analyses going
on or in symptom severity or what have you
no and i'm happy to put anybody in touch
with uh with nada if you're interested
in working on something like that that's
great um so you mentioned people who are
interested in connecting with parts of the enigma
consortium can reach out to the um to the uh
kind of sub-section leaders if you will um what
would uh somebody need to do to say right to you
what would you need to see in order to say okay
these guys might be uh worth taking the risk on to
to partner with we have a number of people
who i'm sure going to be very interested in
sure absolutely one of the best places to start is
to go to the enigma website um and i'm pretty sure
i included that early on in one of the slides and
i can happily send it to you um jack to forward
on if anyone wants to know if you can't find it
with google but there's if you go to the go to
the website we list who all the chairs are in
the various working groups paul thompson has
an absolutely phenomenal project manager who
is sort of a central uh emailing emailinghub
and many many many people will email um paul
and sophia tomopolis who is the project manager
and and say i'm interested in joining and she
usually figures out where they need to go and who
they need to talk to um so i get an email from her
probably once every you know every few months with
somebody saying oh here's this group in israel
here's this group in buenos aires or something
and then we reach out to them and say
hey you know what what are you doing
what would you why do you want to be involved
what are you what are you looking at and um and
just double checking that they can really be a
participant um because um ideally what i was i
was pointing out if somebody comes in and says oh
you know i basically want to build my career on
the backs of all the data that you have collected
um we still go wait a minute hold up hold up
um but if somebody comes in and goes hey
i've got you know 15 schizophrenics and 15
controls i can't do anything with it but i'm
really interested in this question and here's
what i'm doing and can i maybe roll these
methods out to some of these other samples
we're happy to chat with them absolutely
happy to chat with them that's fantastic now
uh one final question is that there are a lot of
different working groups which are very disease
or disorder specific are there any sort of things
which are trying to look across the spectrum of
things to kind of uh identify commonalities which
might exist between i think you had mentioned an
example like autism and adhd but you know might
you have something between you know in other
mental illnesses or other neurological conditions
so look for some of these kind of more um i'm
thinking of things like the the nimh's efforts to
kind of redefine how we think of mental illness
um to kind of look at the the actual um biomarker
patterns and then ask whether or not those map on
to what we think of as schizophrenia for example
are there activities going on like that yeah
absolutely and enigma is very open to supporting
that kind of um of activity i mean the enigma
coinstack grant is exactly taking advantage of
nih's desire to see cross-diagnostic questions so
we can start we start by asking questions within
schizophrenia and then seeing if it generalizes
um to bipolar disorder and major depression
that's the kind of thing that people want to see
there is a cross-disorder working group within
bipolar disorder schizophrenia major depression
and i think attention deficit disorder but it
may just be those first three where we're really
trying to compare results across groups and say
what what is it that we're really seeing that
is similar that is different because there are
even though there are similarities there are of
course disease specific effects such as um the the
propensity within men and women so we do see sex
differences um and just in how many individuals
you get uh with schizophrenia versus bipolar there
are obviously differences in medication there are
differences in the trajectory of the disorder but
what what does that do to the brain and how do
we tease that apart what good does that tell
us absolutely there are folks doing that and
then a number of those papers um that i talked
about in the ohbm are in the hbm special issue are
focusing on cross disorder groups much of that is
organic so we don't have a cross disorder working
group per se we sort of have a an ad hoc you know
effort between this group and that group or these
three groups or those four groups based on common
interests that's really interesting it would be uh
really kind of interesting to see kind of a enigma
perhaps a big mega meta analysis done using
enigma uh to look for brain commonalities
and things which might be um uh uh just kind of
connect what we think of as distinct disorders
that are really kind of kind of different flavors
of the same disorder or alternatively look for
things where we think we understand that there
are they're they're they're called one thing
but they're actually multiple different sub
disorders yeah we really want to dig into that
with these disorders that we know are just not
uniform in any way which is almost all of them
yeah exactly uniform well i i i think i've
run out of questions and it looks like our
participants have as well so i want to thank you
uh dr turner for for sharing with us uh your work
and the work of this impressive international
team on enigma and your work going on at uh
georgia state um to in uh coinstack and all
of the activities going on there that is very
exciting what a fantastic resource that has been
constructed i can't believe it's been 10 years
that enigma has been around i remember when it
was a twinkle in paul thompson's eye so it's
fantastic to see a success story from someone like
him and yourself and all of your collaborators
uh people i really respect and admire so um thank
you very much for sharing that with us i want to
thank all of our uh participants for for joining
in if you are interested in anything enigma uh
you know where to go um and as coinstack as
well uh everyone have a very good weekend uh
thank you for joining us and look forward to
seeing you next week thank you thanks so much